o
eu gosto sempre de começar qualquer ir
fazendo um momento de respiração
consciente
vocês estão sentados na cadeira procure
sentar da metade pra frente e colocar os
pés em paralelo no chão quem tiver pés
pra casa ver que te mantém a distância
dos pés em paralelo à linha coluna
vertebral se sinta que as vértebras
sobre verba estão devidamente alinhadas
e a cervical que é chamada a parte nobre
do corpo está reta também para que isso
aconteça o queixo fica para levar o chão
que o encaixe do crânio na cervical
nós temos uma postura adequada os ombros
para trás e pra baixo
alinhamos as orelhas com os ombros da
narina com umbigo tem temos uma linha
dentro do corpo
segundo nós vamos fazer respiração
consciente inspiramos naturalmente pelas
marinas é passivo o ar entra uma pequena
pausa e esperamos pela boca
ah ah ah ah
mais uma vez queremos pelas marinas
a última vez
e podemos ouvir todos os sons à nossa
volta
fechamos os lábios respiramos
naturalmente pelas narinas a ponta da
língua no céu da boca atrás dos dentes
frontais
estamos absolutamente presentes no agora
inspirando e expirando conscientemente
nada extra apenas seres humanos
presentes às vezes nos falta um pouco
disso no dia a dia
nós não estamos onde estamos cheios de
ansiedade diz querendo fazer tantas
coisas e não apreciamos o caminho eu
fiquei durante 12 anos no japão como um
treinamento monástico e fiquei oito no
mosteiro feminino ea minha superiora
sempre dizia o caminho é onde você está
e é precioso o caminho
nós queremos chegar a algum lugar sempre
e ficamos muito aflitos porque não
apreciamos onde nossos pés estão
queremos lá vai ser bom
o adiante vai ser melhor queremos
sucesso
mas o que é o sucesso sucesso vende
suceder de passar adiante uma coisa que
eu recebo ela vive em mim e eu transmita
a palavra felicidade também verde fértil
de frutífero aquilo que dá frutos
nós somos mais felizes quando nossos
projetos dão certo são mais felizes
quando temos alguma coisa compartilhar
recebemos apenas sucesso felicidade e
poder
como é que o que nós podemos nós podemos
tanto quanto nos permitimos poder é
interessante não é com um poder mental
eu vou desenvolver a capacidade mental
de conseguir o que eu quero não é bem
isto eu vou estar tão presente no que eu
estou fazendo e tão efeito do causas e
condições para que isso se manifeste
estar presente
absolutamente consciente é uma mina de
ouro que eu tenho procurado dar em todos
os lugares que eu vou
você está com problema dificuldade a
ansiedade
respire olhe para o céu um pouquinho
pensa nessa imensidão na qual nós
estamos somos essa partícula mínima de
vida é tão importante porque de lamas e
pensamos mexe e dá na terra
nós somos a vida do que nós somos a vida
da terra tem alguma coisa com o som que
vai pegando
eu não sei se eu mexer atrás estava bem
é importante lembrar que nós não temos
de fora nós não vamos pra fora
nós somos o planeta nós somos o sistema
solar e não existimos uns e outros
quando nós nos apercebemos disso o nosso
olhar para a realidade se transforma
somos o caminho é interessante nós somos
parte do caminho nós somos caminho cada
um de nós ea totalidade manifesta
nós somos um pedaço da vida nós somos
parte de alguma coisa nós somos o todo
manifesto e todos se manifestam em
inúmeras formas diferentes
uma das formas a este corpo humano e
cada um de nós tem este corpo humano
essa bênção porque poderíamos ser
qualquer outra forma de vida mas as
causas e condições foram tais que
nascemos com esta aparência com este
corpo que está se transformando em sexto
tenente todos os nossos sentimentos o
que somos já estava de certa forma
dentro do útero materno
vamos nos lembrar que somos um óvulo
fecundado apenas um óvulo que foi
fecundado e que começou a se dividir se
partilhe se multiplicar e criou esse
corpo humano e que nesse processo de
gestação já recebeu inúmeras influências
que vão de terminando o nosso
comportamento é a nossa maneira de ser
no mundo coisas internas e externas
porque não há separação não há dentro
nem fora e na semam se começamos a
receber influências
quando a gente falava 'papai mamã as
pessoas sorriam e nos faziam achar que
era bom porque se não fosse bom
nós não iremos aprender a falar nós
aprendemos a pensar quando aprendemos a
compreender uma linguagem a linguagem de
nossos pais
a linguagem de um país a linguagem de
uma época mas essa forma de pensar
também se modifica
e quando somos capazes de nos abrir a
novos potenciais novos paradigmas
nós estamos nos transformando nos
desenvolvendo há pessoas que dizem eu
sou assim e eu não mudo de jeito nenhum
ficou travado ficou fechado perdeu a
oportunidade de crescer e de viver
porque a vida é movimento e
transformação
eu me reconheço sempre na face das
pessoas que eu encontro
eu trabalho muito com meditação zen é de
sentar sem acreditar que as pessoas
acham que quem medita então sai da
realidade eu vou sair deste mundo e vai
entrar no mundo
budista búdico o mundo duda é o mundo da
realidade é o pé no chão é o encontro é
o reconhecimento desse mesmo em cada
olhar que você encontra e as linhas
faciais são as faces que eu vejo quando
eu falo eu gosto muito que a luz esteja
na platéia porque eu só por si só posso
falar recebendo
o feedback eu tenho uma posição muito
difícil agora porque o que eu vejo aqui
são sombras e vocês são todos iguais
nesse momento em pequenas diferenças de
luz e eu percebo muito pouco de quem e
para quem eu estou falando isso pra mim
é uma dificuldade
vocês conseguem falar sozinhos
olhando para uma parede amorfa falta o
impacto do contato e este contato é que
a nossa vida em tudo que nós fazemos a
nossa meditação e silenciosa que é
voltada para uma parede eu imaginar que
vocês são a minha parede
eu tô aqui sentado em meditação e nessa
parede se projetam erguer as coisas
algumas formas só meio difusos é o nosso
compreendo muito bem mas alguma coisa em
mim compreende alguma coisa que eu não
posso mudar conceitos e que eu não posso
falar sobre ela mas de uma certa forma
eu sei que eu posso sentir vocês mesmo
sem olhar a sua face
eu posso sentir que há uma certa trocou
a ação uma certa ansiedade uma certa
curiosidade o que é isto o que ela está
falando o que eu usei como que na cidade
eu posso ter menos ansiedade mas nessa
na cidade que temos ansiedade diz a mãe
da sociedade para quem trabalha no campo
para quem depende das chuvas e dos
ventos os cavalos que ficam doentes
a ansiedade em todos nós é uma coisa
humana nós e nós compreendemos se nós
sentimos em profundidade e deixemos que
ela passe que ela saia
ela deixa de ser um obstáculo o caminho
é sem obstáculos desde que você evite
escolher e selecionar e não estamos o
tempo todo escolhendo e selecionado
imagine você abre mão quando você abre
mão o universo inteiro está em suas mãos
você segura uma só coisa e fica a pegada
eo apego impede que você faça outras
coisas eu posso querer beber um pouco
d'água agora mas eu não posso porque
minhas mãos
minha mão esquerda segura meu dedo
direito que eu quero tanto bem e ficou
limitada
então como é que eu posso ao mesmo tempo
ter coisas passar pelas coisas elas
passam por mim mas eu não me apego sem
apegos e sem a versões aquela pessoa não
gosto não há aquele cheiro não é bom pra
mim
os odores todos são moradores que nos
dizem coisas
os sons falo as pessoas os alimentos de
vida que vida eu minimizo sofrimento
sofrimentos do mundo todos os temas
o primeiro ensinamento de luta do carro
do que significa insatisfação todos nós
conhecemos inúmeras insatisfações
todas elas têm causas todas as causas
podem ser entendidas e quando nós
compreendemos nós entramos em nirvana
que é paz e tranquilidade
viver em paz e tranquilidade cada
instante da vida
para isso o caminho de práticas são
muitos aspectos mas cada morto e 18
aspectos está conectado um com os outros
memória correta lembrar se da verdade
nós somos na verdade não existe uma
coisa chamada verdade que está voando
pegar ela está em mim e você em cada um
de nós e na capacidade nos relembrarmos
reencontrarmos revermos a palavra
religião
ela tem três possibilidades né à venda a
mesma raiz que é reeleger e ler de novo
religar e que quando você religar
reconecta e religiosa mente
aquilo que fazemos incessantemente fazer
algo religiosa mente é como tocar o
violino todos os dias por muitas horas
você vai ficando melhor
não sei mais sábio mais fácil mas
simples trabalhar a ansiedade é
trabalhar a respiração consciente porque
quando nós ficamos ansiosos não é assim
o do batimento cardíaco respiração fica
mais rápida então nós nos entregamos com
uma coisa muito simples consciência da
sua respiração pensamentos
eles vêm e vão a raiva insatisfação ela
vem vai é tão rápida quanto um raio
o raio de luvas o resto é memória e
gostamos de estimular memórias que não
são positivas
então vamos começar a estimular memórias
positivas
vamos perceber que somos toda a teia de
possibilidades de pensamentos e
sensações e emoções mas aquilo que nós
alimentarmos é o que vai se desenvolver
eu posso alimentar minha compaixão a
ternura e queria desenvolver a sabedoria
perfeita
como posso ele alimentar outros
elementos em mim aquilo que o alimentar
o que vai crescer e as raízes quanto
mais fortes estiverem mais firme serão
primeiro temos que observar o que
queremos alimentar em nós e no mundo
eu acredito numa cultura de não
violência
eu acredito que cada um de nós é
corresponsável para construir um mundo
que seja menos violento mais acolhedor
mas terno e mais compassivo onde nós não
vamos competir uns com os outros mas
vamos colaborar e criar condições de
respeito à vida na sua multiplicidade de
formas
mas para isso é preciso acordar é
preciso despertar é preciso abrir os
olhos e ver que nós somos a teia da vida
ninguém está separado ninguém está de
fora
eu não posso me recortar da realidade de
ver uma tesourinha e olha aqui estou eu
ea estão vocês nós somos um só corpo e
uma sua vida com tudo que existe todo o
passado da humanidade reside em mim eu
sou o resultado de todas as vidas do
passado da minha ancestralidade e da
nossa ancestralidade comum
vamos nos lembrar que cada um de nós tem
pai mãe avô vos a vós e de uma multidão
e havia menos gente no passado nós somos
todos interligados e pertencermos a uma
única família que é chamada família
humana
biologicamente uma família aqueles que
podem se a casa lar e ter filhos férteis
'nós podemos nós nos casamos com pessoas
de qualquer parte do planeta e nossos
bebês podem ter bebês
para isso não há discriminação ou
preconceito
temos inúmeras tradições espirituais que
maravilha
que maravilha que para nós acessarmos a
sabedoria podemos escolher caminhos
diferentes mas desde que cada um deles
seja o caminho que você perceba a
essência da mente isso a libertação
verdadeira
o resto é o resto você penetrar porque é
essencial perceber o essencial saber
distinguir o verdadeiro do falso
o profundo do superficial e perceber que
no profundo ou superficial faz parte e
que não há nada para ser jogado fora
mas é pra ser apreciado compreendido e
transformada
logo não precisa correr tanto não
precisa de tanta ansiedade mas precisa
de mais presença e apreciar os pássaros
cantando
porque eles cantam tanto nas metas
quanto nas cidades ea vida natural tem
toda parte já não está só nas matas e
nas praias e nas montanhas porque ela
está em você você a vida natural
os bichinhos à sua volta os insetos à
sua volta do de vida
apareci cada instante da sua vida
cada momento cada passo cada inspirar
cada expirar e procure inspirar-se de
tudo que há no universo idade fosse pro
mundo apenas um pouco de compreensão
ternura e cuidado que todos os seres se
beneficiem todas as sérias